dames messieurs bonjour l'actualité
politique fait une sorte de pause
aujourd'hui de l'enfer tout à l'heure le
point sur les dossiers en cours
en revanche le mystère reste complet sur
dans cette affaire de disparition de
brigitte grappin cette lycéenne de 16
ans pour donner sans nouvelles depuis
maintenant le 3 juin
vous savez visière dans la prison de
stockholm le témoin numéro 1 la seule
piste des policiers le photographe de
mode philippe bérot bédouins s'est
suicidé en laissant trois lettres l'une
à ses parents l'autre aux procureurs
suédois est la troisième enfin à son
avocat personne ne sait encore ce qu'il
ya dans ces lettres personne ne sait si
des renseignements pourront remettre les
policiers français sur la piste de la
jeune fille
le problème d'ailleurs de savoir où ils
en sont dans cette enquête et c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
françois cornet a demandé au commissaire
pois blancs qui chargeaient de cette
enquête le de faire le point françois
connaît
eve le foot en france en corner voici le
pour commissaire pois blanc qui sait pas
encore que nous sommes en liaison est ce
qu'elle est les oreilles d'établi écran
ce corner je pense que nous n'avons pas
pour l'instant cette liaison allons
continuer on attend d'avoir la liaison
avec le quai des orfèvres
pour la deuxième fois en quatre jours
c'est une autre affaire les
embouteillages monstres ont eu lieu
aujourd'hui sur l'autoroute du nord à la
suite de l'accident d'un camion
jean paul soete et la circulation était
très ralentie ce matin sur l'autoroute
nord la sortie de la capitale à la suite
de l'accident survenu un semi remorque
il était 7h30 lorsque la remorque d'un
camion chargé de six tonnes de viande
s'est retournée à la sortie du tunnel du
landy paralysant la circulation
jusqu'aux environs de 9h30
malgré les délestages mise en place
immédiatement les embouteillages devait
s'étendre sur plusieurs kilomètres et à
9h30 le trafic pouvait reprendre mais
sur deux files seulement la chaussée
n'était finalement complètement dégagée
que vers 11
c'est quoi un conseil a rappelé à tous
les avis listes qui doivent patienter
bon gré mal gré dans les embouteillages
si ça se produit dans un tunnel
n'oubliez pas de couper votre moteur
cela réduit d'autant la teneur en oxyde
de carbone de l'air que vous respirez
les affaires françaises maintenant on va
d'ailleurs commencer par le problème des
transports cette fois des transports en
commun d'abord à limoges grève de trois
jours des chauffeurs d'autobus qui
réclament une prime de vacances et
manifestations ce soir dans le quartier
de l'opéra à paris une manifestation
organisée par les syndicats et les
partis d'opposition en faveur de
l'amélioration des conditions de
transport
en ce qui concerne la navigation
aérienne la grève du zèle des
contrôleurs de l'air cftc se poursuit on
dit même qu'elle pourrait se durcir dans
les heures qui viennent mais et cela
provoque bien sûr pas mal de retard
encore dans les arrivées et les départs
et savions au bourget à orly en revanche
en ce qui concerne les pilotes
une action est toujours prévu mais les
syndicats ont décidé de laisser passer
le gros du départ du début juillet avant
d'entreprendre cette action au sénat
maintenant cette nuit les sénateurs ont
en sommes rejetés d'une part le principe
de la sélection de en médecine dans la
nouvelle loi présenté par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale rejette également
de la réforme de la loi de juillet 1901
relative au contrat d'association les
halles maintenant et bien finalement
après huit heures de débats parfois
houleux les conseillers de paris ont
voté cette nuit le projet de rénovation
du quartier des halles avec en premier
lieu la démolition des pavillons baltard
les premiers travaux doivent commencer
jeudi enfin je vous signale que dans une
dizaine de minutes quinzaine de minutes
elle doit faire vous présentera une
enquête sur le problème de l'étalement
du temps de travail
un projet a été présenté par monsieur de
chalendar qui est l'un des conseillers
du premier ministre
projet qui consiste à laisser chacun
libre de choisir la ses dates de
vacances la durée de ces week-ends et
même la durée de la journée de travail
alors pour illustrer cela sacriste bâle
a réalisé un film d'anticipation
je crois imaginer comment pourrais vivre
de cette façon une famille française en
1987 un problème important car je vous
le rappelle l'ensemble des problèmes
d'étalement des temps de loisirs coûte
autant à l'économie française que plus
d'argent que la fermeture des usines en
mai 68
rendez vous dans quelques minutes en
attendant la bourse
gérard vidal en chl un accord va être
annoncée entre renault peugeot et volvo
il s'agit de construire en commun une
usine de moteurs je crois oui c'est une
initiative importante car c'est la
première fois que volvo vinci s'accorder
avec un partenaire européen c'est
glaciaux ne fait pas partie du marché
commun alors qu'il ya déjà une
coopération une association très étroite
entre renault et peugeot de quoi
s'agit-il il s'agit de créer une filiale
commune qui fabriquera des moteurs et
chacun des trois portes et partenaires
donc l'arrêt la régie renault peugeot et
volvo pendant une participation d'un
tiers dans cette filiale et les moteurs
seront fabriqués précisément à l'usiné
de douvrin qui est destiné à développer
tout l'équipement annexe de la régie
renault et de peugeot et notamment les
moteurs c'est important car sur le plan
du marché européen dont il y aura une
unité si vous voulez à cette échelle de
l'europe et qui permettra dans deux ans
trois ans trois coups pour que
l'opération devienne effectivement
réalisées faut attendre un délai de deux
ans eh bien ce sera à même de produire
350 milles moteur est ce qui est tout de
même un chiffre assez est considéré en
ce qui concerne la bourse et bien
aujourd'hui la tendance est irrégulière
car les pétroles les grandes vedettes
jusqu'à présent sont un peu plus
discuter non pas la française des
pétroles qui progresse encore
mais surtout petrofina et l'anneau
vernalde la norvégienne de la zone
pardon les autres grandes valeurs
françaises comme la compagnie générale
d'électricité est assez ferme
aujourd'hui ainsi que cheney dans tandis
qu'il ya eu un petit trou sur leurs et
le lingot a baissé voici et la tendance
donc pour aujourd'hui
la liaison est maintenant établi avec le
quai des orfèvres le commissaire pois
blancs fait le point de l'enquète avec
françois corner oui en compagnie du
commissaire pois blancs qui dirige cette
enquête nous s nous allons essayer si
vous le voulez bien monsieur le
commissaire dit voir un peu plus clair
dans cette affaire est la première des
questions que je voudrais vous poser a
trait aux lettres calais s'est dérobé
loin avant de se suicider on prétend
qu'il y en a au moins trois dans l'une
d'elles aux dernières nouvelles est
importante pour votre enquête
en avez vous ou non eu connaissance
non à ma connaissance aucune des lettres
laissées par des roues belouin n'a pour
destinataire une autorité de police ou
de justice française donc je n'ai
connaissance du contenu donc une des
lettres qu'il a pu laisser mail une
telle était adressée aux au procureur
suédois comment se fait-il alors que
près de 48 heures après le suicide de
celui que la police française considère
comme le témoin numéro un de cette
affaire vous n'ayez pas encore eu
connaissance du contenu de ces lettres
notamment celle adressée au procureur eh
bien il faut dire que les transmissions
de renseignement de police la police
dans la mesure où la police peut
elle-même donné ces renseignements et
chouih des impératifs de conventions
internationales et ces renseignements
en tout état de cause ne peuvent nous
parvenir que par le canal d'interpol
donc je suis dans la tente de
renseignement en provenance de stockholm
par ces deux mois qui est la seule voie
officielle mais ne trouvez vous pas
qu'il est illogique justement ce délai
non même pas les logiques
il faut savoir il faudrait savoir si la
police suédoise où la justice suédoise
est en mesure dès maintenant de
connaître d'abord le contenu des lettres
qu'elle a pu trouver et de communiquer
par les voies officielles à la justice
française l'une des lettres l'une des
trois têtes et adressée au père de
dérober loin pensez vous que vous en
connaîtrez le conflit et que par ce
canal vous puissiez avoir des
informations
j'attends de savoir d'abord que quand
monsieur bérubé loin aura reçu lui-même
sa lettre nous verrons ensuite
alors revenons à la sphère purement si
vous voulez on a parlé d'un éventuel
réseau de traite des blanches vers aux
bédouins pouvant en faire partie aurait
pu se donner la mort par peur de
représailles
croyez-vous à cette hypothèse alors il
faut le dire que
en l'absence de tout indice qui nous
permettent de retrouver la trace de
brigitte grappin toutes les hypothèses
sont à envisager
encore que celle que vous évoquez me
paraissent assez peu vraisemblable
le suicide du témoin numéro un de cette
affaire ramène t-il l'anc est au point
mort il faut bien préciser que l'
enquête n'a jamais cessé de se
poursuivre parallèlement à l'audition du
couple dérobé loin et janick poivre elle
à stockholm toujours pour essayer de
trouver un indice qui viendraient
infirmer ou confirmer la thèse de bérubé
loin que tout le monde connaît
maintenant et qui a été de protester
énergiquement quand ce rendez-vous que
brigitte roth grappin aurait dû au
drugstore
comme vous le voyez par le fait qu'il
faut comme dans toute histoire policière
attendre je vous rend l'antenne avocat
n'ajjer merci messieurs à pinon
maintenant les affaires de l'étranger
d'abord à new york hier soir la sestina
un peu mystérieux d'un chef de la mafia
daniel esther c'est au cours d'un
meeting pour la défense des italiens
d'amérique que joseph colombo l'un des
rois de la pègre de new york a été
grièvement blessé à la tête par trois
balles de revolver son assassin un jeune
noir a été tué par un policier joseph
colombo est considéré par la police
américaine comme l'un des chefs de la
mafia il cachait ses activités derrière
la ligue italo américaine des droits
civiques destinée disait-il à protéger
les intérêts des américains d'origine
italienne persécuté par la mafia le
gouvernement israélien a confirmé
officiellement que le journaliste
soviétique victor louis avait bien
séjourné en israël à la fin du mois de
juin
le communiqué de jérusalem révèle que
victor louis a rencontré un conseiller
politique de madame gold amer mais il
précise que le journaliste n'ayant
aucune fonction officielle
il n'y a eu au cours de son séjour rien
qui puisse justifier l'existence de
contacts même officieux entre jérusalem
et moscou
franz paul stang le bourreau de
treblinka est mort dans une cellule de
la prison centrale de düsseldorf all
style était considéré comme l'un des
plus grands techniciens des méthodes
d'extermination des prisonniers détenus
dans les camps nazis
arrêté en 1967 il a été condamné en
décembre 1970 à la détention à
perpétuité après avoir été reconnue
coupable du meurtre d'environ 400 mille
juifs l'impératrice farah diba a terminé
hier son séjour à paris par une visite
au musée de l'homme où elle a inauguré
l'exposition consacrée au peuple iranien
homme du vent et jean de terre
l'impératrice était accompagné de madame
georges pompidou sous la conduite des
organisateurs de l'exposition la
shahbanou et la présidente ont parcouru
les salles du musée de l'homme
recouverte de tapis précieux elles ont
pu admirer les vitrines remplies de
bijoux de miniatures et d'objets anciens
les tableaux ont retenu tout
particulièrement l'attention des
première dame d'iran et de france
l'impératrice connaît bien ses peintures
qui font partie d'une collection qu'elle
vient de racheter à londres afin
d'enrichir le musée qu'elle est en train
de faire construire à téhéran
il
avant de passer aux problèmes de
l'espace vous signale la mort ce matin
dans une clinique de nancy de
monseigneur pierre ollaire sevec tenancy
et primat de lorraine monsieur
monseigneur pérol est âgé de 73 depuis
le 6 juin il tourne là haut les trois de
saliou ton dit françois de closets que
l'équipage aurait reçu l'ordre de
revenir dans les heures qui viennent sur
terre ça d'ailleurs au moment où à
houston etats-unis américains
soviétiques par le d'amarrage expérience
d'amarrage entre les cabines des deux
pays
oui sont deux informations qui se
recoupent sont très intéressantes alors
d'une part la fin très probable
aujourd'hui probablement demain du vol
de dobbels qui volent stocks et pas de
ça y est ce un vol qui aurait donc duré
24 jours et 24 jours c'est évidemment le
plus long vol qui a été accompli jusqu'à
présent mais si vous voulez une
référence les américains préparent la
station orbitale skylab est lé premier
vol des équipages à bord du skylab
serait aussi à peu près d'un mois
le problème est de savoir si un autre
équipage l'équipage saliou et d'un
soyouz 12 irait ensuite reprendre la
relève en quelque sorte de soyouz 11 à
bord de saliou car il se peut très bien
que les systèmes de bord de saliou ce
soit encore en parfait état de
fonctionner enfin nous aurons des
informations là-dessus probablement ce
soir ou demain
deuxième problème les études sur la
compatibilité des systèmes spatiaux
c'est un problème fondamental c'est
celui du sauvetage spatiale qui est en
cause
au départ on ce n'est pas beaucoup
occupé il n'y avait pas de possibilité
et puis après le tram d'apollo 13 tout
le monde s'est posé la question mais
enfin pourquoi ne peut-on pas venir au
secours des astronautes
on s'est dit pourquoi les soviétiques en
particulier ne peuvent pas venir au
secours des astronautes américains
et bien la réponse était simple parce
que les systèmes n'étaient pas
compatibles sur ces images vous allez
voir comment se réalise dans les deux
techniques les amarrages qui permettrait
à des astronautes en détresse
éventuellement de passer d'un vaisseau
dans l'autre voici l'arrivée
dulayme lorsque au retour de la lune il
vient saari met ainsi au module de
commande payée la partie sur la partie
supérieure
le points d'arrimage et voici maintenant
un soyouz qui bien au rendez vous d'un
autre soyouz et qui va s'arrimer
d'emblée vous voyez tout de suite que
les systèmes ne sont pas cons baptisé
par même km ce ne sont pas les mêmes
quand c'est dur sont pas les mêmes
systèmes d'accrochage il s'agit pas
seulement de faire une liaison mécanique
mais des liaisons électriques voici le
docteur petrov
le grand spécialiste soviétique de
l'espace qui un et aux stones regarde
ces problèmes alors voilà ce que nous
pouvons évoquer une séparation entre
vaisseaux soyouz que vous voyez
maintenant se détache et là évidemment
d'un autre
soyouz est de la même façon demain
probablement soyouz u 11 se détachera de
saliou qui voyez le soyouz qui s'éloigne
et vous allez découvrir maintenant le
vaisseau apollo qui s'éloigne également
après ce que les américains appellent un
taux qui donc les deux systèmes ne sont
pas actuellement vous le voyez qu'on
patine c'est la vie ce qui n'entre pas
dans le pas de vis il faut donc repenser
tout le système est ce qu'il y a de très
intéressant c'est que ce travail se
poursuit sérieusement à preuve que l'on
parle du côté américain d'une expérience
commune entre américains et soviétiques
qui aurait lieu probablement 74 avec les
américains et aucun vol prévu entre 73
et 70 cette ville envisage de faire un
vol avec un soyouz est un atout l'eau
pour essayer la compatibilité des
systèmes d'une part apollo avec les
soyouz et les saliou d'autre part les
soyouz avec les skylab et les apollo
américain ce serait une expérience parce
que ce sera une expérience à des
informations passionnantes
passons au second maintenant l'équipe de
marseille l'olympique de marseille est
rentré hier dans sa bonne ville avec son
titre de championne de france
une réception avait été préparée bien
sûr par les supporters ça a été la fête
pendant des heures d'ailleurs voici
quelques images commentées par
jean-claude joueurs
1948 1971 23 ans après l'olympique de
marseille obtient un titre de champion
de france sur le char de la victoire
avaient pris place autour de monsieur
gaston defferre député maire de
marseille le président leclerc et tous
les joueurs de l'olympique de marseille
nous avons connu en 1969 l'ambiance et
qui a régné lorsque les marseillais
avaient remporté la coupe de france
nous avons vécu avec les joueurs les
réceptions et l'accueil qui leur a été
réservé au retour de colombes mais
l'ambiance qui a régné hier à marseille
pour cette marche triomphale à dépasser
l'entendre
nous avons vécu hier un après midi show
dans une ambiance indescriptible
un enthousiasme délirant débordant un
véritable triomphe à la manière je suis
l'américaine trompettes et pétards
klaxons confettis serpentins corne de
brume et 20 30 40 ou 50 1000e supporters
qui formaient cette haie d'honneur
cette véritable marée humaine
toutes les tenues vestimentaires et des
permise et les inscriptions sur les
banderoles à l'est du pont bla jax
l'olympique de marseille arrive à celle
de l'om nouveau champion d'europe
le cortège péniblement quitta le stade
vélodrome vers 17h en direction du
centre de la ville circulation
totalement interrompue et si la devise
de l'om reste droit au but
on peut affirmer que tous les records
d'embouteillages ont été battus hier en
fin d'après-midi le trajet boulevard
michelet mairie vie à préfecture
effectué en quatre heures d'horloge un
record difficile à bas à la préfecture
où s'effectue à la première halte et où
monsieur laporte communiqué le
télégramme de félicitations adressé par
le secrétaire d'état à la jeunesse et
aux sports monsieur joseph comique
l'olympique de marseille a donc remporté
hier une des plus difficiles leur
encontre de son existence
aidé en cela par son public qui lui est
à nulle autre pareille
la voyez fait des shows à marseille hier
restons dans la compétition mais sur un
ton un peu plus calme au moment où
s'ouvrent les vacances et les onze
heures de loisirs voici un ouvrage qui
peut vous être utile
c'est le guide du bridge que vient
d'écrire une spécialiste de ce jeu
madeleine blomet le bridge
c'est une passion parfois un snobisme et
aussi bien souvent une sorte de mystère
pour des gens qui comme moi il y en a on
appris au moins dix fois sans avoir
encore des comptes et vers le décompte
des points ce guide a pour objectif de
rendre les choses plus claires dans ce
jeu qui passionnent des centaines de
milliers de français
d'ailleurs c'est la première question
que christian d'y apposer à l'autre à
l'auteur combien de français
sutil au bric c'est un jeu qui se
démocratise pour coup il ya 40 millions
d'euros globalement bien à peu près un
million en france
c'est quand même énorme non ce n'est pas
compliqué au départ ou des bars en rouge
vif aux 13 points pour annoncer ou 14 de
large
on vous inculquer quelques notions et
hop vous l'argent la nature et plus vous
jouez plus que vous apercevez que ça lui
est difficile
et on retrouve la même donne à peu près
tous les 6 milliards 37 m
jean plus bonjour en tournoi et je pense
qu'un joueur deux parties libres qui
veut progresser jouera au tournoi
automatiquement
alors on peut jour pour moi chez soi
c'est à dire organiser un diptyque est
atypique est achevée lois individuelles
parler quand elle parlait
et je me suis aperçu qu un lugeur en
prenant à l'étranger francophones ne
sait pas quoi faire de lui le soir ils
pensent qu'à jouer
c'est pourquoi j'ai eu l'idée de l'ordre
donné mon club avait les appréciations
d'un guide
il se range ils peuvent signer s'ils
peuvent consommer les boissons
alcoolisées ou non le tarif s'il ya des
tournois les jours de tournoi les jours
de compétition les hommes jouent
beaucoup mieux que les femmes parce que
les femmes sont toujours sollicités par
autre chose en france qui vont faire à
dîner le soir l'heure à laquelle va
rentrer mari je pense qu on triche
inconsciemment même quand on ne veut pas
si l'on est habitué un partenaire ce
qu'obtenaient reconnaît vohrer sûr vous
connaissez les siennes et vous trichez
mais ça c'est de la tricherie
inconsciente
bon il ya aussi électrique chili c'est
l'adage public un conte brodeur il vaut
mieux qu'une mauvaise passe alors vous
allez j'en faisais bridgeurs qui se
penchent que laisse tomber leurs
lunettes alors il se porte généralement
c'est bien entendu ils n'ont pas les
jeunes alors pas vrai que je suis plus
subtile suspens oui il ya la tricherie
psychologiques m et alors là on en
compte ces points en remuant les lèvres
oui enfin
votre partenaire qui est habitué à vous
sera exactement votre nombre de points
c'est même la passion extrême abric
joueurs qui aiment le brige ne pensera
plus qu'à ça que ça se meut levé son
cocher téléphonera pour demander son
partenaire pour quelle raison il a mis
lundi à la baisse de 3,7 à la plage du 4
il pensera sein des jeunes continent et
après il ira jouer
en somme il ne pense qu'à ça vous
rappelle le titre de guide du bridge par
la madeleine blomet édité chez denoël et
doit faire maintenant
l'étalement du temps de travail
35 millions de français sur 50 millions
vivent aujourd'hui dans les villes le
monde moderne la société industrielle
est fondée sur la concentration urbaine
elle est fondée sur la division du
travail il est fondé sur le mouvement
des gens et des marchandises sommes très
loin de la vie villageoise de l'époque
où le travail était champêtre et où les
fêtes étaient essentiellement religieuse
dans sommes très loin et pourtant nous
continuons à rythmes et toute notre
activité sur le calendrier qui était
celui de la vie villageoise ont les
mêmes horaires nous avons les mêmes mois
nous avons les mêmes semaine seront les
mêmes années est ce normal
monsieur vous pensez que non vous et que
vous venez de publier un livre qui
s'appelle l'aménagement du temps et dans
lequel vous proposer un calendrier pour
l'an 2000 un calendrier de la société
industrielle
j'ai fait lire votre introduction à
jacques triste va lille 1-1 petit film
que je vous propose de regarder ensemble
mathus et c'est plus je vois que je vais
bien dormir ce soir à quelle heure tu ne
veux pas ça dix étoiles
c'était aussi un lien on a bien rigolé
mais je trouve que les traditions se
perdent ou l otan de m
calcutta c'est bien simple plus ça va
plus dans la vie les acteurs à pied vers
l'or
j'adore oui à quelle heure ont-ils au
lycée marc à 8h30 et patricia un peu
plus tard demain c'est lundi oui
aujourd'hui tu veux dire payer 5 heures
de sommeil ces êtres cours des mois
tu pourrais peut-être mais laisser se
débrouiller seuls pour leur petit
déjeuner dormir un peu plus non ces îles
sont grands maintenant confirmé c'est
comme ou chocolat qui le précède
non mais j'en profiterai pour faire des
courses demain dans la matinée qu'elle
aurait en fait eu 12h30 5 heures bon
j'ai envie de faire 10h16 heure ça me
fera cinq heures
ensuite on a prévu un petit enis avec
l'ami robert nous qu'après la piscine
puis je rattraperai mardi 11 ans 9
heures ça convient on n'a rien prévu
ah oui très bien parce que moi mardi je
vais mater bouchées doubles et comme ça
ça permettra de 5,15 énorme match et
mayo sava dame cas il est à l'aise mais
tu verras quand même à la piscine ah oui
j'allais dormir comme un plot bonsoir
monsieur pardon bonne nuit chère madame
j'ai été ravi que vous m'accordez cette
soirée
au jardin des biches et ajouts
ça va breux du courage petit ça c'est
ton avenir hockey dont je hais les 16000
sa soeur fils tel aviv déjà plongé dans
sa géographie
c'est vrai on n'y pense jamais assez
tous les jeunes tous aussi que dans un
moment sympa trop de même tu sais les
croissances m hirsch au patin
aujourd'hui en 1981 l'enseignement et
audiovisuelle le cours magistral est
donné par des téléviseurs installés dans
les classes
une première expérience avait été tentée
il ya une dizaine d'années aux crs de
marly des puits elle a été améliorée de
même la semaine est réduite à trois
jours de cours obligatoires pour les
enfants pour le reste ils viennent
lorsqu'ils le désirent pour tous les
travaux pratiques ainsi ils peuvent
décider de leur distraction ou partir en
week-end avec leurs familles l'essentiel
c'est qu'ils fournissent comme leurs
parents une certaine somme de travail
est allé sur le mois et même sur l'année
ils sont tenus de fréquenter l'école
pendant les 7 mois de mauvais temps mais
d'avril à septembre
ils peuvent prendre leur temps de
vacances en une ou plusieurs fois s'il
le désire comme les professeurs et pâle
aussi leurs vacances l'école reste
ouverte douze mois par an de leur côté
les professeurs se consacre surtout aux
travaux pratiques
puisqu'ils sont libérés des cours
magistraux et aussitôt terminé le court
que les visées la discussion commence
avec les élèves
témoin la réponse sec - 2 voici ce à
quoi ainsi deux mois sans parents
professeurs ont acquis une grande
liberté de mouvement mais cette liberté
consiste alors à décider à l'avance ce
qu'on fera le lendemain le week-end
suivant ou l'été prochain
salut chez robert tu fais toujours aussi
anglais tu as tout cas toujours aussi
pressé tu es en retard ne commence à 10h
tu vois j'ai regardé ça ira puis on est
passé minute près toi tu joues bien sûr
angèle et abricots la réparer j'y
réponds week end
à part ça on se retrouve toujours tennis
et bien sûr à 4h30 et travaille pas trop
pour être en forme
t'inquiètes pas j'ai une raquette 9 et
faire pleurer si monsieur bardot ne met
que dix minutes pour aller à son travail
c'est qu'ils utilisent les transports en
commun pour mettre fin à une circulation
automobile anarchique
les pouvoirs publics ont pris il ya
quelques années une grande décision
désormais les grands axes de circulation
ne sont plus réservées qu'aux soldats
d'obus
seuls quelques uns étaient de la voiture
s'agglutinent encore dans les petites
rues quant aux trottoirs et aux rues
commerçantes
elles sont exclusivement réservés aux
piétons
sales usa
il est vrai cela met tranquillement
décontractée auplata le haut des marches
sur le compteur horaire dynamique deux
premières vous ouvriez donc le matin
viennent met une fiche dans ce compteur
mais à quoi sert le panther le compteur
celle d'une feinte a comptabilisé
lorsque la personne aviv à son poste de
travail
introduit la carte dans son lecteur
le conteur commence a totalisé c'est à
dire qu'il cumule le nombre d'heures
qu'ils passent à son lieu de travail le
soir que lorsque la même personne 120 il
retire son badge et le compteur s'arrête
cellfish cette fiche là je prends par
exemple la fiche de monsieur vallée qui
lui un jusqu'à présent totalisé 160
heures sur le compteur sur le calendrier
mensuel nous sommes le 23
normalement il devrait avoir 150 3
heures donc une à cette heure d'avancé
avec ses 7 heures il peut lui
pratiquement dans les jours à venir en
faire ce qu'il veut c'est à dire arriver
en retard
théoriquement ou et pour partir plus
tard le soir
mais chaque employé de même des horaires
obligatoires oui nous avons un horaire
fixe
voilà sur ce tableau où a lieu la
journée de travail
ça m'aurait fixe de 10 à 12 et de 14 à
ensuite nous avons trois plages
d'horaires dynamique pendant lesquels la
personne peut pratiquement faire ce
qu'elle veut c'est à dire soit pas
arrivé plus tard le matin partir plus
tôt le soir
manger à midi le temps qu'il faut
rendement utilisés certain nombre
d'heures à sa guise
est ce que pour vous cette horreur
dynamique et rentable
cette oreille et même rentable pour
l'entreprise c'est à dire que ne
s'impose plus si vous voulez les gens se
retrouvent à l'aise ne sont pas
bousculés ni le matin ni
soir et sous divers points les gens
pensent à leur travail ce qui
effectivement est également une bonne
rentabilité pour notre pays merci
alors oui oui tout s'est classé
mithouard madame bardot est secrétaire
de direction
son patron lui demande une seule chose
être là à certaines heures fixes pour
dicter le courrier et transmettre les
messages pour le reste est à la
condition qu'elle fasse un nombre
d'heures requises
elle a toute liberté pour organiser sa
journée de travail
ainsi elle peut concilier son métier et
son rôle de mère de famille elle avait
renoncé à travailler lorsque ses heures
de travail et des fixes
quand l'entreprise est passée au
roulement elle a repris ses activités
travail mais si ça peut être conservé
aujourd'hui j'étais là bas tu as des
problèmes avec ça mais j'avoue tu as eu
de la veine et j'ai joué comme une
savate et on dit ça on dit ça on verra
ça demain pendant la revanche le
lendemain impossible je te connais qui
tremblent déjà
c'est pas ça du tout mais je rattrape
aujourd'hui je fais 9 heures jeudi si tu
veux je suis ton homme
ok mais le matin alors oui à 8 heures
après on part en week-end là pour 8
heures vous allez en fleurs oui je
prends mes trois jours la quinzaine
suivante je l'aurais comment dimanche
il ya un gros arrivage de travail et un
coup de collier à donner chacun son tour
ah oui
piscines piscine nos femmes doivent y
être déjà
bon mais puisque nous sommes au dessert
il ya quelque chose qui intéresse tout
le monde
oui sa passion ah bon tu viens avec moi
là oui et toi moi je veux en norvège
avec le lycée du van et au 6 juin
mais tu seigneur régler ça en janvier
c'est marqué sur le planning du lycée
j'ai payé et touré tous ses marchés
pas de panique alors si j'ai bien
compris
patricia tu viens avec nombreux times du
5 au 20 juin ensuite à maman et moi nous
revenons ici
et toi tu vas rejoindre ta grand-mère
annecy jusqu'au 8 juillet nous sommes
bien d'accord je suis bien à ton tour de
norvège qui va rejoindre passera d'ici
pour la dernière semaine
c'est bien ça faux marabout pointe je
supporterai pas très longtemps je sais
qu'en mère patricia chica plaît ben oui
tiens des mines et à alon patricia bon
dix mois plus tôt si on garde 15 jours
pour le ski vous n'êtes pas de casser
quelque chose oui il reste encore dix
jours et ce alors moi et ça c'est une
surprise et on a encore le temps d'y
penser
oui en attendant au lit les enfants à
l'ewi silence
non aujourd'hui c'est juin arrête moi ça
tu veux avec moi c'est non mais il s'en
fout quand même apparu ils sont ils ont
complètement fou ils veulent nous faire
croire que dans dix ans on travaillera
35 heures par semaine
non mais n'importe quoi lors du
n'importe quoi et puis tu vois ça toi
les gens allaient travailler quand ils
en auront envie là quand ça leur chante
rade nord comme on va à la faillite
ah ça on y va et plus vite qu'on ne
croit ça tout le monde veut des loisirs
oui ça des loisirs on en a plein la
bouche des loisirs s'amuser travailler
le moins possible mais gagner beaucoup
d'argent à sa wii à ça à gagner beaucoup
d'argent
aa pour refondre 7 chacon très bien
qu'en cas de romain heureusement nous on
verra procès à quoi toi moi ça m'aurait
bien plu
bon évidemment évidemment toiture elle
fait toujours rêver
moi j'aime bien aller me coucher tient
au revoir
première constatation donc on vient de
le voir dans le film les gens ne font
pas tous la même chose à la même heure
les enfants partent en classe à des
heures différentes sommes bien d'accord
oui je crois que le système actuel elle
ne pourra pas durer indéfiniment
je crois qu'il voudrait que les
entreprises petit à petit je crois que
le feront d'ailleurs assouplissent leur
rythme de travail hebdomadaire de la
même façon que le rythme quotidien et
finalement de la même façon que le
rythme annuel nous retrouvons sur le
problème de l'étalement des congés si
vous voulez qu'il ne peut se résoudre
que par un roulement que par un
assouplissement du système de travail
dans beaucoup de l'administration dans
beaucoup d'entreprises
il n'est pas indispensable il est de
moins en moins indispensable que tous
les employés soient présents toute la
journée
exactement aux mêmes heures que tous les
autres employés il y à qui vous voulez
un certaines parties du temps de la
journée par exemple dans un bureau où il
est nécessaire que tout le monde soit là
pour le téléphone pour les réunions pour
le travail en commun et puis il y à des
travaux personnels que ce soir en
atelier à l'atelier d'usinage par
exemple ou bien et dans une
administration ou dans ses shows sial
d'entreprise des travaux personnels que
vous pouvez parfaitement faire à des
heures différentes des autres
le problème c'est d'assouplir de
permettre à chacun d'arriver à des
heures différentes
et peut-être à des jours différents vous
admettez donc gens continueront à
vouloir fuir la ville aussi souvent que
possible donc vous admettez qu'on a
absolument raté la croissance des villes
je constate le fait actuel je ne juge
pas je constate le fait c'est qu'un
nombre très important de citadins
peut-être parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
jardin ou parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'équipements collectifs loisir et de
sport suffisant époux aujourd'hui le
besoin de s'évader
je n'y peux rien je ne pense pas que
d'ici 10 ans on arrive à restructurer
complètement les agglomérations urbaines
et ça m'est proposé l'aménagement du
temps c'est tiré la conclusion du fait
qu'on a échoué dans l'aménagement de
l'espace
je sais que vous voulez je constate que
l'aménagement de l'espace
malgré tous les efforts n'est pas n'est
pas parfait ceci dit on peut encore
faire des progrès et on fera
chez les lieux de travail et les
logements on y pense d'abord on peut
améliorer et augmenter les équipements
collectifs ça c'est évident il faut le
faire mais encore une fois dès l'instant
qu'il ya des problèmes de déplacement et
de loisirs ont fait un pays du monde
aucun régime politique aucun
gouvernement ne pourra faire que tous
les habitants d'une ville donnée puisse
utiliser la piscine ou le tennis ou la
salle des fêtes à la même minute n'est
pas possible ne trouve pas plus ou le
métro ou le train pas plus encore une
fois dans une famille je le raconte dans
mon livre
vous avez en principe un lit par enfant
et parfois une chambre et vous n'avez
pas une salle de bain pour chaque enfant
à moins d'être vraiment très très riche
pourquoi mais a simplement parce que la
salle de bain on s'en sert à quart
d'heure par jour où une demi guerre
qu'est ce que vous voulez et qu' on ne
va pas faire la dépense c'est idiot et
d'une salle de bains par enfant utiliser
une des meilleures parle ou pas c'est
pareil pour le métro si on voulait
multiplier les métros ou les où les
roues les rues ou les autoroutes de
façon telle que chaque français puisse
s'en servir à la même minute et bien ce
serait un gaspillage assure que personne
ne pourrait supporter accepté donc il
faut simplement que la plage de temps la
durée d'utilisation de ce genre
d'équipement soit plus grande donc les
gens n'utilisent pas tous au même moment
je crois que c'est qu'une loi
fondamentale
oui vous proposé de diviser le l'année
en deux parties à la fois pour les
entreprises et on le verra plus loin
pour les écoles qu'est ce que vous
proposez pour les entreprises je crois
que dès l'instant où on ne peut pas en
france imposer comme on le fait dans
certains pays
je crois à l'esm aux employés aux
salariés de prendre leurs vacances par
exemple
même à la proportion de la sur 12 en
novembre ou de la sur 12 en janvier ou
de la soude en février il est clair que
les français n'ont pas envie partir en
vacances au fond les petites vacances
d'hiver si vous voulez courtes n'ont pas
ravi de prendre leurs vacances principal
dans la mauvaise saison
ils ont envie de profiter du soleil
après tout si comme eux et vous aussi
les sports le problème simplement c'est
que ces périodes de vacances puisse
s'étaler non pas sur le seul mois d'août
mais sur 3 mois 4 mois ou 5 mois
pas forcément d'ailleurs avec la même
densité des bars à chaque mois cela
n'est possible que si les entreprises au
lieu de fermer à date fixe roulent les
industriels ne veulent pas fermer par
roulement ses traits ne pas fermer ça
dépend il ya tout de même près de 60%
des entreprises françaises qui roule par
contre dans certaines branches est plus
difficile à organiser
mais c'est souvent une question
d'améliorer l'organisation et peut-être
aussi d'habitués
nous habitions à ne pas nous considérer
à tous les niveaux comme indispensable
accepté de faire confiance à notre
collaborateur pour peu il nous remplace
qu'on ne sommes pas là mais faire
confiance à un collaborateur c'est aussi
prendre le risque que ce que l'agora
turs se révèle supérieur au titulaire du
poste non il ya un petit risque
c'est bien pour ça d'ailleurs que
forment pas mal d'entreprises le patron
n'aime pas beaucoup que la boîte tourne
quand philippe allard nos espaces
étrangers exemple dans l'ensemble les
entreprises étrangères
pratique et de façon beaucoup plus large
que nous le roulement en allemagne j'ai
appris récemment que le roulement est la
règle est on ne peu une entreprise n'a
pas le droit de fermer pour les congés
si elle n'a pas l'accord du personnel et
du comité d'entreprise ce et le système
inverse de la france il est certain que
dans la mesure où l'industrie emploie
des machines de plus en plus coûteuses
et des modes de plus en plus vite
cela peut être plus et alors ça c'est
l'aspect économique allemand il est
clair d'ailleurs vous le voyez
actuellement dans les affaires comme les
ratings pétrole comme les roses
industries chimiques
il n'est pas question de fermer on lui
reste ouvert toute l'année le personnel
france ont plongé par roulement et en
général il en est très satisfait dans
les affaires comme des bdr dans les
banques dans les assurances
le roulement ne pose pas de problème
social et on m'a même dit je crois que
c'est vrai que dans les entreprises où
le roulement est organisé le climat
social est meilleur seulement il faut
pas que les décisions soient prises en
haut au niveau du grand patron andy d'en
bas vous partirez à telle date vous à
telle date vous laissez les gens
s'arrangent et au niveau des petites
groupe de petites unités de 52 100 200 à
ce moment là bas on tient compte des
situations de famille
remarquez qu'on y arrivera vraiment que
si on arrive aussi à aménager un peu
mieux le rythme scolaire
je pense que dans l'état actuel des
choses il est pas raisonnable
d'envisager de manière vent à long terme
le maintien du départ en vacances de
tous les petits français
à la même date que ce soit honneur au
midi ou dans la même ville alors quelles
solutions pratiques proposées
franchement c'est un problème très
difficile je crois qu'il ne se résoudra
que petit à petit par une modification
rénovation si vous voulez des méthodes
pédagogiques qui permettra à l'intérieur
des établissements scolaires d'envisager
un assouplissement du rythme et
peut-être de laisser après tout l'école
ouverte toute l'année on a parlé par
exemple de diviser l'année en deux
semestre
non non on a parlé vous en parler on en
a parlé même dans des milieux et de
recherche pédagogique et je crois bien
qu'on en a même parlé la semaine
dernière au parlement
c'est c'est tout même
on peut concevoir que pendant un
semestre il y aurait à rythmes de
travail très assez serré et qui surtout
correspondrait aux méthodes pédagogiques
avec la classe homogène les mêmes
maîtres les mêmes élèves pendant ces six
mois ou ces sept mois c'est peut-être
pendant la deuxième partie d'année
pendant la belle saison les le travail
scolaire pourrait être organisée
autrement de façon à permettre aux
parents qui voudraient pour des raison
ou une autre sérieuse partir en mai ou
en juin ou en septembre et aux
professeurs qui voudraient faire pareil
de le faire est d'assurer en
contrepartie une activité de scolaire
réduite à a limité à un certain nombre
d'enfants et de professeurs pendant le
mois de juillet et même pourquoi pas
pour le mois d'août
je suis donc préfère donc une année
s'est divisée en deux parties un univers
de 6 ou de sept mois pendant lesquels on
travaillerait au rythme actuel dans les
usines et de façon classique dans les
classes et puis en été de 5 mois pendant
lequel on pourrait pratiquement où les
sortir de là
nous sortir de l'école pour prendre des
vacances de manière beaucoup plus souple
on l'a vraiment commission et l'enfant
serait sûr de pouvoir retourner dans une
classe et d'être pris en charge quand
ils seront livrés l'important qu'il ya
beaucoup de parents qui seraient bien
contents de pouvoir trouver un
établissement scolaire qui les
accueillent pendant les mois de juillet
et d'août c'est ce que vous avez sonder
le corps professoral sur vos projets les
premières réactions vous le savez sans
doute on était assez réservé même très
réservé lorsque l'idée a été mise en
avant il y avait là quelques mois j'ai
l'impression que une évolution
actuellement est en train de se faire et
que en tout état de cause on commence à
y réfléchir sérieusement dans les
groupes de recherche pédagogique vers
l'enseignement public et peut-être plus
encore dans l'enseignement privé
le problème est de savoir maintenant
comment on peut y arriver quel type de
mesure il faut prendre pour arriver à
faire entrer dans les faits un
calendrier de ce type
je crois que la première chose c'est que
nos concitoyens ils réfléchissent
prennent conscience du problème et ne
considère pas que le système actuel de
chacun déplore n'est ce pas tous les
sondages le prouvent et ne considère pas
que ce système actuel n'est qu'une
fatalité inexorable à laquelle on ne
puisse rien changé c'est la première
chose à deuxième une fois cette prise de
conscience assuré il faut que du côté
des pouvoirs publics leur leur tâche
n'est pas de conseils à leur donner
enfin ce serait je crois de lever les
verrous et notamment d'assouplir une
réglementation beaucoup trop uniforme
beaucoup 3 centralisée ce serait de
décentraliser les décisions au niveau de
l'entreprise et l'établissement de
permettre des variantes permettent à
chacun de s'arranger de façon différente
de l'autre s'ils le préfèrent et puis
d'encourager notamment dans le domaine
scolaire
l'expérience de passage à deux semaines
ou si vous voulez à l'école ouverte
toute l'année peut-être y at-il aussi
d'autres mesures
c'est aussi donner l'exemple non c'est
ce que j'avais dit il ya donné l'exemple
au niveau de l'organisation du travail
parlementaire du travail administratif
il est certain que les systèmes actuels
abouti à une surcharge de travail pour
tous les cadres supérieurs dans le
secteur public comme dans le secteur
privé en mai et en juin et que cette
surcharge les empêche même s'ils le
souhaitaient même si le boulet de partir
en vacances à ce moment là et en
revanche il ya un arrêt presque complet
entre le 15 juillet et le 31 août qui ne
facilite pas le passage roulement et le
maintien d'un certain certaines
activités question à des conseils des
ministres au mois d'août
je ne suis pas qualité pour vous
répondre deux mois indique le monsieur
le premier mini c'était le dossier de
l'étalement du temps de travail au
tournant la bourse maintenant il ya
actuellement beaucoup d'assemblées
générales qui font le point marche des
entreprises
la dernière en date gérard vidal ans et
celle de saint gobain pont-à-mousson oui
et je dirais qu'il ya aussi le problème
d'étalement des assemblées car c'est une
période qui est complètement bloquée
dans la dans l'année c'est stupide car
les actionnaires sont obligés d'assister
à 20 25 30 assemblée dans une matinée et
dans une après midi où pensez bien que
c'est strictement impossible et je crois
que là aussi des progrès seraient à
réaliser car finalement les dirigeants
sont amenés à se voter un blanc seing à
eux mêmes alors que les actionnaires ne
peuvent pas exercer directement leur
droit de contestation à l'intérieur de
ces assemblées ou tout au moins ne peut
pas s'instituer un dialogue entre les
dirigeants et les actionnaires
alors saint gobain pont-à-mousson ça a
été une grande assemblée effectivement
car 70 a été l'année de réorganisation
l'année de remise en ordre pour ce très
grand groupe
les comptes consolidés les comptes du
groupe avec ses filiales ont été pour la
première fois publié et ce sont des
comptes qui ont été établis selon les
règles américaines
j'en déduis que probablement la société
à
l'arrière-pensée d'introduire ses titres
à new york dans les années qui viennent
deux chiffres sont à noter l'actif net
par action représente 208 renvoyer que
le cours et 243 francs ce qui donne une
idée la sous-estimation de cette valeur
et le bénéfice net est toujours par
action de 12 francs 50 environ
le président monsieur roger martin a
souligné que l'année 71 le wat est bonne
et les résultats devraient être en nette
augmentation
restons si vous voulez dans l'air
liquide dans la chimie avec l'air
liquide qui annonce également des
résultats sensiblement supérieure pour
l'exercice en cours
engin matra en hausse et un des rares
titres qui se distingue assez nettement
aujourd'hui sur les pétrole il y à des
prises de bénéfices et bien logique
après un mouvement très fort depuis deux
à trois mois
aquitaine en baisse de 7 francs esso
également françaises de raffinage la
grande filiale la française des pétroles
et pratiquement à son cours de la veille
voici le cours de la norvégienne de la
zone qui était très attendu voyez que le
cours d'hier était 2062 on avait même
atteint le taux record de 1080 à 84 je
rappelle que cette valeur peut t 400
francs il y à peine trois mois donc
c'est une progression vertigineuse et
bien aujourd'hui il ya des prises de
bénéfices encore une fois c'est tout à
fait normal
klein villa est en baisse du côté de la
borne laboratoires pharmaceutiques on
constate certaines baisses actuellement
notamment l'institut mérieux bellon se
sont repliés sur bélon il ya une légère
baisse des bénéfices semestriels
c'est une tendance qui est à noter alors
que les allemandes sont un peu plus
ferme aujourd'hui notamment un siemens
et là bas hier voici tout de même des
hausses dans différents secteurs
cheney dhr gagne de francs 30
aujourd'hui l'assemblée s'est tenue et
des déclarations intéressantes ont été
faites par monsieur forgeot le président
en effet la fusion entre les deux
affaires du groupe
de travaux publics la sitra et spie
batignolles a été annoncé et d'autre
part le président a déclaré que la
valeur de son titre était de l'ordre de
430 francs pour un cours qui étaient
donc inférieure inférieure de près de
45% ce qui montre encore une fois la
sous-estimation cette valeur donc une
séance assez terne avec tout de même
quelques points de fermeté sur le marché
de l'or le lingot a baissé 7205 je vous
l'avais annoncé tout à l'heure contre
7230 et puisque nous sommes dans la
période et a semblé je vous présenterai
rapidement que nous n'avons pas le temps
un document que le rapport de bsn
rapport de bsn qui est assez remarquable
dans son illustration et dans la volonté
de ses dirigeants
d'expliquer clairement l'information non
seulement aux actionnaires mais hossa là
c'était la bourse de paris avoue paul le
faire et bien cette addition de télé
midi du 22 juin maintenant terminé merci
de votre attention et bonne journée